morning Millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy hum day Iggy make
sure to hump someone you love today
unfortunately Theo's not here so it's
looking like Jackie is my next
humpy is it really hump day though if
Theo's not here and let's talk about the
fact that he's just skipping out on work
left and right that's a very interesting
philosophical question you pose is it
still technically hump day if Theo is in
here and according to my research yes
according to my research no it's just
Wednesday and in regards to Theo coming
to work it's it's his mom's fault to be
honest like with the new studio like I'm
on a new schedule and I need to just get
my [ __ ] together before I start bringing
my son so before you start giving us
crunch angel Dora yeah but that doesn't
mean we can't give the people crunchy
angel Dora precious Qian Dora beautiful
lovely Dora love of my life Dora I miss
Sam Dora apple of my eye Dora
perfect man Dora Corinne she lips Dora
beautiful fat Dora soft an angelic Dora
smooth and furry Dora and scene you know
the thing with the Dora song is like it
could go it's the song that never ends
it just goes on and on my friends some
people started singing it not knowing
what not knowing what it was but will
just keep on singing it and it is just
because no that's what it is yes it is
and knowing but they'll continue singing
it forever just because this is the song
that never and it just goes on and on my
friend some people started singing and
not knowing what it was what they'll
continue singing it forever just because
yes that honestly feel like that is my
key that's something like that something
beautiful go into an audition American
Idol
ha ha ha hi Ryan I'm gonna be singing
the song that never ends today thank you
for having me yeah that's beautiful
speaking up okay so yesterday was
probably one of the best days I've had
since quarantine started one for shallow
reasons obviously like my special came
out and there were so many like I
literally was over well you know what
said when you're talking to avoid for so
long and you just talk to your Instagram
stories and you talk to
camera like for a while it feels like
there's nobody listening and I know we
have analytics and I know how many
people listen but sometimes I just feel
like nobody likes like I really feel
that way and with the special like I
couldn't believe how many people were
tagging their story it's like I actually
couldn't keep up with all the stories
and all the reviews and like literally
my show got to number four overall on
iTunes and number two I couldn't be the
stupid [ __ ] Steve Carell comedy ain't
a trash I bet you it's trash and the
reason it's so bad it was whatever I
digress
but it's really it's still and now when
I went to bed last night it was number
four when I woke up I was number five so
keep purchasing keep reviewing if you're
looking for places I have all the
information now so it's available on a
ton of platforms Amazon Prime Apple TV
which is iTunes Vimeo google play tons
of places and if you're looking to
youtube you can buy it on youtube or
rent it on youtube if you're looking for
any of the places I have a highlight of
my Instagram story now with all the
information and I just truly appreciate
everyone just really showing up from the
comedy special and I've gotten such
positive reviews and then selfishly not
selfishly the day yesterday was so
amazing because we spent like half the
day with our niece and she is just she's
really something she it was in part for
me to hold her and not like squeeze her
so hard
no it's and like not to just walk out
the door take her home with you and
never to return
throw her in my purse and just - yeah it
was not really hard she's really
tempting really tempting so it was just
a great day and I'm feeling like
invigorated with this newfound love and
appreciation for life and I haven't felt
that way in a while and it's good the
toaster so thanks guys thanks guys and I
hope everyone enjoyed the special I mean
what's not to enjoy I'm really excited
to watch it I still have it watch it
because you know I like to save I like
to save my content like I don't I'm not
watching it as homework I will enjoy it
I had actually so much to do yesterday
we recorded the redheads episode will be
up tomorrow morning I think you guys are
really gonna enjoy it so if you haven't
read the book yet or you haven't
finished make sure to do that soon
before the episode drops and tomorrow's
also our last episode the week because
it is a holiday weekend and we will be
back on Tuesday of next week
so that's just a little programming
scheduling update and anything else not
not at the moment not at the current
Junction I think we should just get into
the stories of the day
because there's one story that um is
taking over my life
it's taking over my life because I've
forced it to I really like to believe
that what if we didn't do this job like
I really wouldn't even be on my radar
well I think that's also why my day
yesterday was so good because I watched
so much of the YouTube drama content and
it's not as juicy as it once was but it
felt like we were like getting back to
you know normal life you know that like
just the simple days where vitamins were
just up for discussion yeah but like the
simple days of drama get it yeah and
before quarantine like before we knew
what it's like to be so bored yeah I see
that well we're gonna get right into it
in the Fast Five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast and today
we also have two your toasters so it'll
be a nice long episode for everyone
again - your toasters our advice segment
you can always email us totally
anonymously dear toasters at gmail.com
if you want us to read your query on air
is that the right word query we're so
smart
okay first story the story of the day
Totti West Burke says James Charles feud
started from jeffrey star and Shane
Dawson's poisonous lies okay yesterday's
hottie West book dropped a video called
breaking my silence it's a 40-minute
video in which she explains sort of the
events leading up to what inspired her
motivated her and gasps let her to make
the video last May about James Charles
called by sister she says that Shane I'm
just you know paraphrasing Shane and
Jeffrey really filled her mind with lies
about James Charles encouraged her to do
the video author to edit it yet him
being this monster she already had
concerns about him and his fame and his
entitlement but then after talking
extensively with Shane and Jeffrey she
really thought that making this video
was the right thing to do to like sort
of stop him in his tracks and get him
off his phone before a bunch of victims
came forward and Shane said he was going
to do a documentary with a bunch of
James Charles's victims they had played
an audio file for her of a conversation
with one of his victims that I guess
really tugged at her heartstrings also
being a victim of abuse victim of sexual
assault and so all of these events led
up to the coachella sugar bear hair
reverses
Herman hey don't halo vitamin kerfuffle
which that point was the thing it was so
it wasn't all about the vitamins but the
vitamins were the thing that brought it
back to like her beef with Jane right
and she made that video so according to
her video basically she never really
like thought much about some of James's
odd behavior but only when she became
friends with Geoffrey and Shane did they
poison her and Gaslight her into making
this video and encouraged her very
heavily and like gave her the knife in
which to stab him in the back and I want
to take this chronologically because
there's so much to unpack here but let's
just start with taught to use video
because after drama get in which that's
what they call it after drama get in I
think the world pretty much after all
the videos took James's side yes it's
funny because now I'm thinking back on
it I feel like the way that I left drama
get in I felt like James was right I
think I felt that Tati was a nice decent
person I don't think her video was
filled with lies it seemed like there
was a misunderstanding that none of us
could really reconcile but we were both
fine with James and Tati
James was uncannily Tati was like going
down and subscribers after she had
really gone up but I don't think it
definitely harmed Tati because like she
is she something about what she was
saying was untrue because James was able
to refute it but I did feel like there
was this piece missing
because Tati seems like a decent person
I have a feeling we're about to agree
disagree I heard I heard a bit of your
phone call more definitely not to
disagree okay and and James what had the
receipt so I definitely felt like I was
on both of their sides even though those
sides conflicted with one another yes I
I agree but you know what as a fan I was
such a big fan of James Charles and
takis video totally poisoned me and then
with his video like I believed him but
something about it like I actually and I
just think of myself like as a fan of
youtubers like I haven't watched really
much James Charles content since then so
like even though he did you know what's
the word with an R redeemed himself I
definitely think that video took a toll
on his career in in the numbers of it
all because I myself stopped watching
even though I believed him yeah it's
just like I was I was over it yeah so I
agreed there was something missing in
the sense that nothing made sense like
how can this two people be telling the
truth and I don't think either one of
them were lying like I don't think
chachi is a lie
and I do not think James Charles is liar
no everyone told their version of the
truth yeah I remember when we talked
about toddy we were like who is this
person she seems like such a precious
gem woman and this was before James's
rebuttal so she just seemed like this
really sweet kind person and I do think
she is still that person but obviously
there were things going on behind the
scenes that affected why she made that
video so in the video now let's bring
into present-day in the video except
that video drama Gethin took place in
May and according to her video in
December her and James made up and
December was after Shane and Geoffrey
series came out where they didn't bring
up drama Kenan they didn't have anything
without victims and they totally left
hockey out to dry and so I think even
though wait there was a she contradicted
herself in her own video because she
said that they totally cut her out of
the video she wanted to like she was
supposed to be a part of the series but
then she also said she declined to be a
part of the series altogether so did
they cut you out or did you decline well
it seems as though um she was talking
about like remember when there was like
a I guess it's like a trailer for the
ship yes series and it looked like they
were gonna talk about drama get in
because they had it in the trailer but
then she asked them not to but then the
episode it never happened and then Shane
and Jeffrey were just like said we
decided not to focus on all of this and
so I don't know really where she stood
but like the fact that Jane Shane and
Jeffrey didn't get their hands dirty
then I think she really waited for that
to come out thinking that might redeem
her and when it didn't her and James got
together to talk about their but both of
their experiences yeah okay that's how I
rather I agree and I'm sure that's what
happened but like for me at least I
don't know I just have a hard time
believing that like talk to us Burke is
38 years old she's built an amazing
company she's like one of the richest
youtubers from halo to Totti beauty to
her youtube like she is incredibly smart
incredibly successful she's been in this
game for a while she was above the drama
forever and I just feel like it's a
really convenient theory like for her
like she I don't see this brilliant
smart beautiful woman being gas-lit that
easily by two people she barely knows I
just don't and I don't see her throwing
her like long friendship and mentorship
with James Charles he was at her wedding
I don't see her so easily throwing him
under the bus because people she met for
a month told her to well it was more
than a month but I just I it makes sense
I don't think she was lying in any way
like the timeline and all the facts it
did how did you get sure maybe people
can poison your mind and you'll think
differently about James but to go and
make that video login to your channel
right to make that video which requires
so much time effort energy scripting you
know editing strategy yeah to get it up
it's a lot of work for someone who's not
that interested in taking down another
human being yeah I don't know I just
felt like she didn't really take
accountability for her what she did to
James and to be honest like when I
started watching the video in the
beginning I was really angry on behalf
of James like he got [ __ ] in this
whole thing like he never once asked me
a part of any of this he let jeffree
star do his merch with killer merch like
he was just me as far as I know he was
kind to everyone in the space and
everyone definitely was you know a
little jealous jealous of his incredible
historic success yes so for me when I
started watching this video I was like
angry aunt for James I'm like this is
really unfair because as far as I know
there's no victims of abuse coming out
against him as far as I know that was
just a rumor so I'm like this kid who's
20 years was 20 years old at the time
had the whole world turn on him because
according to talk to us perks she got
gasoline I don't know it just seemed so
like she wasn't taking accountability
for her part in all of it like she
really put it all on James and Shan and
I'm no apologist for sorry Jeffrey and
Jane and I'm no apologist for them but
it does seem like convenient timing I
don't think the time he's convenient at
all like we've really all put this to
bed and even in the comments that I've
read people are so beyond over this I
mean the timing in the sense that like
Shane is now on the chopping block for
his abhorrent behavior people are
wanting to cancel jeffree star youtubers
are just like not it's never been a
worse time to be a youtuber it's
obviously never been a worse time to be
an influencer because there is this sort
of reckoning and people looking into
your past and Shane and Jeffrey are huge
topics of conversation they've been
tweet trending on Twitter for weeks like
and you know I just think that I don't
know it all it adds up but in a lot of
ways it makes no sense to me yeah but
you know what Stu in the beginning of
this video I'm like why am i watching
this MV on board I don't even care
anymore and like you how can these two
morons coerce you to make a video a
whole video it's a lot to make a video
and that's how I felt but then she
started talking about the rest of her
year and what happened afterwards now
her business is supper
and how she could barely get herself
together and how she was supposed to
start fertility treatment she couldn't
even do that because her mind and her
body like could not have handled that
and like the constant anxiety that she
lived with in the past year and I know
exactly I mean actually I mean I don't
know exactly what she's talking about
but I know that feeling of just like pit
you know the whole world hates you and
she's been in that position for a whole
year and so now she's just sharing what
happened from her perspective I do think
that her and James got together they
have these text messages and receipts at
around sharing and they're putting
together a story I don't know if the
story is exactly what happened on Jeffry
and Shane side but I think even knowing
that Jeffry and Shane had a little bit
of involvement and influence rocky
making this video makes a lot of sense
by the way I thought all along not Shane
honestly I don't I don't think Shane
really gives a [ __ ] about what goes on
in the beauty YouTube community back
then he wasn't even a part of it I don't
really feel like becoming a part of it
he was like that back then is when they
were filming this series it was like
learning makeup and making a palette I
don't know I just I don't get the vibe
that like Shane had much stake in this
game but like Bobbi I've thought for a
year now that Geoffrey was definitely
involved in Tottie's video either with
like helping her put it together or some
of the evidence like I have always
thought that and I've always pretty much
thought that Geoffrey was jealous of
James but then like his weird video
never doing this again did it make sense
there's so many things that don't add up
here and part of me when watching her
video like I don't think she was fake
crying and I don't think that she really
lied about anything I don't think Tati
is a bad person like I don't think she's
one of these actually a very good person
me too
who got herself in a situation that she
could not get out of and she was not
prepared to handle she's just not like
that she's been on YouTube for like ten
years and she just does beautiful lovely
content she doesn't get involved in
drama that's not her brand some people
that is their brain but thrive off of it
the more drama the more like Fanning the
flames they live for it but to me she's
like a fragile soul and she can't handle
that and I don't think anything she said
in the video was a lie and I don't think
she was being disingenuous and I don't
think she was fake crying I just wish I
don't know I just feel like it was this
the part about her like not taking any
responsibility for the video and just
like really blaming it on Shane and
Geoffrey like that was too easy for me
like you
uploaded the video you edited that is
like a weeks process like I just I don't
know it was it was a little too
convenient for me okay well I also want
to talk about shame because he went live
as he was watching Tottie's video I
don't know if he had completed the video
and she had again
what a mess mess I mean I saw some
snippets of his live on it was only two
minutes what you saw was the whole thing
oh okay
it was a complete train wreck like him
accusing her of fake crying not once did
I think that her tears were fade and
then one upping her abuse with his he
was like really I was milady with the
worst one possible move he could make in
deleted and tweeted this is such a
[ __ ] lie yeah it was it was terrible
to be honest and that really and he
didn't absolutely nothing to help his
case that to me just made Tati look even
more reasonable a grateful um I though I
was really confused and I'm still like
not sure where I stand because like at
the end of the day I don't think
anything talked he said is a lie I think
she's a lovely person and I think she
got caught up in a situation that she
was not equipped to handle but some
things aren't adding up for me and I I
posted it on our Instagram and I really
wanted to know what people thought
because with with the vitamin stuff like
it was so clear how everyone felt with
Tati and it was so clear how everyone
felt with James and right now I feel
like we got no clarity like the audience
the world hasn't taken one side and so I
just wanted to see what people were
saying on her Instagram and would like
to share some of the comments from
someone in bath she said Shane has
always seemed so sketchy to me I bite a
cheese story she has always seemed real
okay I mean that's beyond subjective but
yeah Hanna said I think the fact that
her and James made up proves that there
is a truth to what she's saying agreed
with that
there's no way James would forgive her
if this wasn't the truth and that they
were both being manipulated by them also
Totti was not problematic at all before
all of this true I agree with that
Alison said Jackie ain't no finally
getting an apology publicly was nice
everything else and if you're in the
youtube community for a long time which
I have not been there's deep rooted
drama with Jackie aina and she got
justice last night which is also
fantastic I also want to say the way
that taki was like in the beginning of
the video on the end of the video
talking about like the YouTube drama in
general like and you know
things are gonna come out and she's
scared for her life like I literally is
it's like the Mafia yes this community
and isn't really like that where there
these people are just so dramatic my
feeling was that she was being a little
dramatic but it's clear that she's had a
very hard year and she's very anxious
and that was clear like in the way she
was talking about security relocating
legal statements we're putting together
what's going on here is crazy but in my
mind it's not necessarily like illegal
no but I also think a lot of some of her
message underneath the surface was that
more things are gonna start to happen
and she was this was kind of like a
warning to everyone and I think she made
some interesting points even though she
was so vague it was painful painful and
I'm so slow to get to her point she was
but she was trying to say I think like
the way that we all sort of gang up on
someone when something like this happens
even when you know we all ganged up on
James based on her video is something
that we need to stop doing and also at
the end of her video when she says like
if you want to cancel someone or you
don't want to be a fan anymore it's what
we're always saying like by all means
walk away focus that energy on yourself
on a different creator but the hate and
like the vitriol of going after people
it can't keep happening right and in the
beginning of her video she said
something incredibly profound when she
was talking about like the way people
feel about felt about drama again and
like all for James all for Tati and the
way that we have like freedom of speech
but it's so limited because if you don't
agree with the heard like you're
automatically cancelled for your
opinions which is so evident given the
climate that we're currently in and it's
actually crazy like even in our comments
about drama again and like the way that
we attack each other like you guys
people are allowed to have their own
opinions even if they're different than
you it's what makes this country great
and you have to stop you like if you
have ever attacked someone in a comment
for their opinion on a random issue like
you are the problem
yeah and I don't know how many times you
have to hear that in order for it to get
into your head like this toxicity that
exists like in the beauty community and
like within the Fant fandoms is because
of people just [ __ ] attacking each
other for no good reason and it's insane
but I digress I want to keep reading
people's opinions because I just find it
so interesting from a h loves life my
only thought is that I listen to a
two-minute clip of Shane talking about
children in the most horrific way I need
not know anything else about this man I
agree with your stance on cancel'
culture but this man needs serious help
and should by no means ever have a
platform again period couldn't agree
more
couldn't agree more um and that's why
it's like I think in a lot of ways this
was a good time for Todd to use video to
come out because nobody is really gonna
defend Shana Jeffrey right now no I mean
I think everyone wants to hear from
Jeffrey I don't think anyone wants to
hear from Jane really ever but what does
Jeffrey have to say about this and I
think Todd he knows that Jeffrey is
gonna a storm is brewing and Jeffrey's
gonna rain down on them but I think
she's prepared for that and it was more
important for her to tell her truth than
to live scared of Jeffrey this next
comment is something I saw a lot and
it's she's a grown woman she knew
exactly what she was doing next part of
me does agree with that like I don't
know how much a 38 year old successful
businesswoman can be manipulated by two
other people into doing something so
drastic I I don't I don't know if I
necessarily believe that 100% yeah
that's I mean that's a fair point and
then the last one from Anna
respect the hell out of her calling them
out really appreciated the apology to
Jackie
aina that seems to be a popular opinion
and I agree with it so once again we
don't know at least this you know first
of all I'm so glad we have something to
talk about that's just like silly like
yeah you know what I mean but it's just
so interesting because with the drama
get in first round
there was really no what confusion for
me it's like I was firmly on tatty and
then I was firmly on Jane like you know
what like that's the problem like you
like nothing is ever so cut and dry you
know when especially when like people's
emotions or people's perceived like you
said like someone Shan said something
too talky and taki took it as like some
sort of undertone with it so when people
are starting to interpret what other
people are saying like yeah it's really
not so crystal clear so when someone
puts out a video and we're all like
hundred percent we know what happened
these are the facts and it's really only
one person side and not the whole story
like that's not valid that yeah like so
the everyone feeling so strongly we
shouldn't I honestly I feel like feeling
confused about what happened here is the
right way to feel I feel like
everybody's confused as we should be
because we weren't there
yeah I'm just I I just feel like Tati in
a lot of ways like she does she does
need a break like it's clear that she's
not cut out for this type of YouTube
space I think for years she was just
like her own person and her own boss and
her own lane and I don't and I've seen a
lot of people thinking she was fake
crying and I don't agree with that like
I do think she is this like little
birdie
like she's agile and I think she has a
lot of hurt in her heart and a lot of
pain and I think that a lot of it has to
do with she feels really guilty about
what she did to James and like I I would
too yeah that's not on that so what did
Trish say oh she I didn't watch Trish's
video everything it was so messy like
these youtubers like they just like make
me nauseous with the jiggly camera like
it's so insane but she watched a video
and was just like commenting on it
throughout and she is Shane's best
friend so like the video was a little
silly because she like really did defend
Shane even though she said she wasn't
you know like his actions are
inexcusable but like I don't know I
couldn't get on board with it because
she was just like ignoring the mazur
elephant in the room which is that your
friend did and said some of the most
vile disgusting things I've ever heard
in my life but she does not believe
Totti at all like and she actually said
that her and Geoffrey are not friends
anymore like they had this moment in
Vegas for something about a purse and
she's like been really hurt by him for a
while
but she hung out with him a lot and he
she never heard him say anything about
like having blackmail on other people
and she doesn't think that that's true
that talked he said that um and she just
really didn't believe anything she
wasn't buying anything talked he was
selling and she actually did make an
interesting point um that I thought was
interesting where she really believed
the whole time like talk to you was
definitely upset about the vitamins and
like the vitamins was her cross to bear
and like that's what this whole thing
was about and all the gaslighting stuff
is a lie and at the end of the video she
makes a point to say which i found so
interesting that Geoffrey is actually a
co-owner of morphe yeah which is
fascinating and she thinks it's no
coincidence that morphe is now coming
out with hair skin and nail vitamins and
so Trish was like that Trish thought
that that was like a window into what
this whole thing is about like it's
obviously still about the vitamins which
you know I it is an interesting concept
but just she said the thing about morphe
I thought it was most interesting that
she said that Morphy and James were
supposed to come up with a makeup line
together too and it doesn't make sense
why James Charles doesn't have a makeup
line of his own
aside from collaborations like his
morphe palette which is like one of the
most successful right now it's a mystery
James Charles Beauty seems like that was
in development with morphe right Jeffrey
star is a secret co-owner so he put the
wheels in motion to get James canceled
so that wouldn't happen and I know
everyone's over this story but like I'm
not and I need to hear from Jeffrey you
know like this has been a hard week for
Jeffrey star stands because you know
he's on the chopping block for you know
things he's done he's done in this past
and you know he has to be held
accountable and you know part of being a
Jeffrey stars stand is like you know
he's problematic but like you just
looked past it like and you just love
him and you think he's funny and you
love his beautiful house and his
products but now it is it is a time for
people to be honest and accountable and
if he's sitting on as many receipts that
I think he is I think it'll make for a
very interesting video and or he could
really shock people and be like I have
no blackmail on anyone by like honestly
that's what I would do because she has
painted a picture of him and if he puts
out a hurricane of a video he's playing
into exactly what she said he is yeah
the video be like I don't know anything
I excluded from this narrative one that
I never asked to be a partner I am sure
he has receipts on absolutely everyone
I've never been more sure of anything in
my life but if he literally just stepped
back and was like no I mean I didn't
really like James but like that was it
and he didn't put up any screenshots of
no voice my mother no text messages he
would rewrite the narrative I think if
if anyone at team star is listening
that's what I would do that's the only
way to get himself out of the hole that
talk to you just threw him down got it
also something that you said that you
felt like Tottie's this video is
convenient because like Shayne is
canceled so of course everyone's gonna
agree with Tati because you can't take
the side of chef Shane and Jeffrey right
now everyone hates em yeah but I also
think I saw it differently where it's
like knowledge she's piling on to his
cancellation and it's time to take down
Shane Dawson it's like she's actually
making him a part of a conversation
that's like so light and you know you
know exciting for people and not
controversial that now like
we we want to hear from Shane Dawson
right and even though like we actually
don't want to hear from him that's true
I think it's kind of like weirdly
reviving him hmm that's interesting you
know
yeah that's an injury but that is an
interesting um the take take thank you I
can't speak English it's just it's all
too much but I'm living for it yes so
we'll keep you posted
yes I look forward to develop this story
developing I hope Geoffrey doesn't just
ignore it even though what Trisha said
was so fascinating it's like there's
this kind of mentality in the YouTube
community is just to like ignore all
criticism and ignore ignored that's how
it goes May she said that's the david
dobrik mentality where it's like there
are definitely questionable things that
they do in say in their videos something
maybe like a little fat phobic we're
like racist innuendos but it's all in
good fun and it's humor and everyone
laughs and whatever um and that's like
the david dobrik vlog scott away just
like you know Archie [ __ ] hates the
vlog squad she [ __ ] towards him oh
here I know you don't I'll explain so
there's so many members of the bot log
squad and there's definitely like a
hierarchy and someone who's super high
up is Jason and he's like 40 years old
and he hangs out with these kids and
like that's his chick and that's his
joke he's like a stand-up comedian David
totally revived his career he has kids
and he dated Trisha forever
and so Trisha used to be in the blog
squad videos and it was like this
fabulous YouTube culmination of life and
they broke up and had a nasty breakup I
don't know all the details but now she's
like now she just hates the Vox squad
and she horse who knows more about them
than her she hung out with them forever
so she's always just like spilling tea
am I getting this right Jillian yeah
okay Jillian's like the YouTube resident
Stan like she was on it way before me so
I should to make sure that I'm not
mistaking facts but I think I'm right
okay cool so much to know in youtube
history like I feel like when I first
started getting into YouTube like James
Charles Jefferson are like maybe two
years ago like I knew nothing and I feel
like I still know nothing yeah and
there's so much history there is so much
yesterday so I'm just hanging at one
scandal at a time one skin a lot of the
time but for this one I think we're I'm
leaning towards Stassi a oh my god I'm
leaning towards tapti
but I have my reservations about some of
the things she said and I'll leave it at
that
okay but I do but at the end of the day
what I want to happen out of all this is
absolute justice for James Charles yes
ah very sad yes I also want to hear from
James Charles
he had wanted to be in takis video or
sing and I think that that's that would
be nice to hear from him and also to
hear him like forgive Tati so that like
we can forgive Tati
but it's not on us to forgive Tati she
didn't the fact that I tried to ruin our
career the fact that James forgave her
like I could never be that forgiving of
a person ever cuz honestly I'm still mad
at talked to you for what she did to
James and the fact that James forgave
her um it says a lot that's what someone
in the comics wrote and I totally agree
it says it really says all you need to
know about this yeah I agree
okay moving on putting it to bed for now
sadly SIA reveals she's a grandmother
after her son had two babies they call
me Nana see his family just got a little
bigger again one month after revealing
she had adopted two teenagers who were
quote aging out of the foster care
system this singer appeared on Zane
Lowe's Apple music show on Tuesday to
share that she's become a grandmother
after her youngest son welcomed children
of his own quote my youngest son just
had two babies she shared I'm just
immediately horrified no I'm cool they
call me Nana I'm trying to get them to
call me lovey like Kris Jenner call me
lovey during the interview she also
spoke about her decision to adopt
explaining that while her son's actually
could have remained in foster care until
they were 21 she wanted to get them out
of the system so they could have a more
stable life quote I'm a little bit jaded
now after investigating the foster
system as much as I have done in the
last year it's failing us not in my
experience in my son's experience
they've been in 18 different locations
in their 18 years Wow
the more I learn the more that sialic
opens up about her personal life she
used to be very very private like with
the wig and everything but I feel like
the Kardashians I brought out the first
monster in her you know and I absolutely
love that and I just love that word
learned every time I learned something
about her private life like I just fall
in love with her even more and this is
no exception I love the cheese of
Grandma I love it she even in her
grandma she still stands the Kardashian
right and that's really all you can hope
for from a lovey that is all that you
can hope for I'm happy for her and her
whole family and I agree I love that
we're getting to see a more personal
side of SIA she's had such an
interesting and she talks about it in
carpool karaoke and she talks about it
sometimes in interviews but where I've
heard her talk about it the most is
carpool karaoke where people were just
always so confused about like the wig
thing they thought it was like an
artistic choice and it really wasn't she
was from Australia and she got like kind
of popular in Australia
as I could singer-songwriter and she
immediately couldn't deal with the fame
and got you know um I think she was
addicted to alcohol and or substance
abuse I don't know but she went down
this spiral where like she couldn't deal
with like that small modicum of Fame
that she had and so she went to rehab
and she you know got her life back on
track but she loved singing and like she
didn't want to give up even though she
knew it was like this toxic part of her
life
so like the wig and covering her face
was this means of like her following her
dreams being passionate about her art
but not falling back into the trap
because nobody she goes to Target and
like nobody really knows and I think she
did that for like ten years and now I
think she's at a place where maybe she's
comfortable with her sobriety and
comfortable with her fame where she can
expose herself to the world and open up
and I hope she's having a good
experience with it because I'm loving
learning more about SIA and her family I
hope so - she really reminds me of
Hannah Montana um
you know obviously she couldn't be a pop
star and go to school and just have a
normal life so complicated so she had
the best of both worlds um
due to her wig I would love to hear a
see a cover of best of both worlds
she gets the best of both worlds she
does even though like now she's
well-known like everyone knows what she
looks like yeah thanks in large part to
the Kardashians
okay next story a little T David Foster
actually a little T hmm what's the word
a little lack of T okay David Foster
quote will never disclose why he
divorced Yolanda Hadid oh my god this
again this is episode should be called
dredging up old [ __ ] because wow I
haven't thought about them and so long
he's moved on he shouldn't talk about it
no but um there's a new documentary
about him called David Foster
off-the-record um and so he refused to
say why he divorced his fourth wife
Yolanda but insisted had nothing to do
with her illness when the two split in
2015 a mid Hadid battle with Lyme
disease the record producer was roundly
criticized for leaving his wife while
she was sick he says in the documentary
how can I leave a sick woman the fact of
the matter is that was not the reason I
left it was for a different reason which
I will never disclose that had nothing
to do with her being sick they were
together for nine years and married for
four before announcing their split in
2015 I mean to meet a story like the big
message is that there's a David Foster
documentary about
but also it is always nice to really get
a little bit more insight into what
happened there because that was a crazy
time it was but it's not some one of
those things I wonder about there are
certain celebrity conundrums that will
literally stay with me till the day I
die like what happened in the elevator
with Solange and jay-z you know like
those things follow me and with in terms
of Yolanda and David Foster I don't
really think about them that much in my
opinion I don't think he left her
because she was sick um
because first of all that's a [ __ ] up
thing to do and second of all he's a
celebrity like his PR team would have
you know shown the optics on what that
says about him and he would have I just
I just don't believe it yeah and he just
said it so I choose to believe David
Foster yeah I mean it begs the question
okay what was the reason then but you
know what like we've moved on and
looking Yolanda ever said that that's
what happened no she just let it imply
that yeah she never said anything in her
silence was an implication that it might
have been the truth but they I mean I
mean I guess they were like so happy oh
by the way speaking of Real Housewives
we did a whole patreon episode yesterday
yeah that people are loving it's all
about every Real Housewives of tag line
ever and our analysis of them and just
talking about old housewives old season
their place in housewives history pretty
much like things that happen on
housewives before we ever started doing
a show so just really dredging up old
stuff yeah that's the theme of today and
it's really great so head over to
patreon calm the morning toast if you
are a big house-sized fan and if you're
not there's tons of other content there
for you to consume it's $7.99 a month
for five extra episodes and if you buy
now you get access to all the old
episodes so it's like really $7.99 for
200 episodes and that's honestly a great
deal great deal okay also speaking of
Real Housewives here's a crazy story
okay Dina Manzo's ex-husband hired a
mobster to assault her current husband
in 2015 the feds say do you remember
when dina manzo house wife yeah and her
boyfriend got beat up yes
turns out allegedly according to the
feds that Tommy Manzo her ex-husband set
it up here's the story
Tommy Manzo the ex-husband a former Real
Housewives of New Jersey star Dina Manzo
was arrested Tuesday on charges of
allegedly hiring a member of the
Lucchese crime family mob whoo I'm sorry
Tommy Manzo Dena's ex-husband do I
understand that so is Tommy Caroline's
sister oh I was talking to mother
I always thought Caroline and Dina were
full sisters not through marriage yeah I
guess her sister-in-laws Oh interesting
so that's the like the bravest between
them it's not that big of a deal people
act like she doesn't talk to her sister
but she's her sister
it's her sister-in-law yeah yeah I agree
that's weird
was arrested Tuesday on charges of
allegedly hiring a member of the
Lucchese crime family mob to carry out
an assault on Tina's current husband
Dave Canton in July 2015 US attorney
Craig carb Nieto announced in a press
conference that Tommy of Franklin Lakes
New Jersey allegedly hired Joe Poorna of
Cedar Grove New Jersey to assault Dave
according to the indictment Tommy gave
John a steep discount for a lavish
wedding reception the following month at
the brownstone in Paterson that Tommy
co-owned and if you watch Real
Housewives of New Jersey you know that
the Manzo's ie Caroline Manzo own Alton
as well Wow
wait this is so interesting you know
Dina Manzo's life after reality TV was
far more interesting than she ever was
on reality TV with her ugly cats but we
had to suffer through that you know this
is fascinating like wow wow you know in
the beginning of Real Housewives of New
Jersey there was like a mob vibe yeah
they never really spoke on it and the
reunion Caroline said like most people
think that but like mmm like they were
all very vague about it yeah
but there was always like this
underlying not anymore at all but there
wasn't with the Manzo family that
brought it in yeah also there were more
Manzo's now there's zero Manzo's on the
show right there was Jacqueline who was
married to Joe Enzo yeah there was Dina
and there was Caroline and then we were
following around Albie Chris and we were
and and their daughter Oh Lauren yes so
we were stood by the right people loved
Lauren to this day she's like an
influencer and I think she's had a child
and her in Vito or like married and they
like eat Parmesan cheese together and
it's so cute
good for it good for that it sounds like
a lovely life so we are when Manzo
embraced her inner grey she's not red
anymore she's full gray hat whoo I love
that for her so we were very much in the
Manzo family and apparently they have
ties to the mob allegedly allegedly
please don't hit us next we are just
reporting on the news it's just so funny
how like when you think of mobs like
back in the day like Godfather there is
like an element of like glamour to like
it was like this rich everyone on a
limousine like mob mob mob and now when
I think of like modern-day mobs it's
like so tacky you know it's like Mob
Wives real houses in New Jersey it's
like not nearly as glamorous as reality
TV has really ruined the mom yeah yeah
somebody think about well we'll keep you
posted on that story really crazy stuff
fifth and final story some exciting TV
news a little TV news courier enthusiam
Curb Your Enthusiasm Oh returned for
season 11 on HBO Larry David will return
to HBO for an 11th season of Curb Your
Enthusiasm this comes after the tenth
season of the comedy aired on cable
network earlier this year
so apparently Larry is already writing
how can he not be how can he not be he
said believe me I'm as upset about this
as you are
haha one day I can only hope that HBO
will come to their senses and grant me
the cancellation I so richly deserve oh
my god that's so funny I mean they say
it's always gonna be the last season and
part of me actually believed that this
season was gonna be the last season I
think it would have been the last season
but if not for Curtis Wright one because
like I need to hear Larry David's take
on Colonel virus and I think Larry David
is literally stewing in his house
thinking of I mean quarantine was made
for Larry two and two because like the
quarantine opportunity for Larry David
to write about quarantine it's just so
right ya know and like just the ideas
were probably coming to him in his sleep
like Susie and quarantine like there's
too much Susie inquiring honestly I need
like one-hour episodes every for like
six years like this I could literally
I'm just so excited about it like this
is fabulous this is the best news like
entertainment news I've heard yeah one
because I was like letdown that there
wasn't gonna be another season and then
second because if there was gonna be
another season like it would be so
iconic with just what's going on in the
world yes Wow um this is fabulous like
it's just a great day to be at you I
need to hear about Susie and Quarantine
I [ __ ] love Susie I sent my love
Susie yeah okay should we dive into dere
toasters which is our advice segment
let's dive
well today's episode end the dear
toaster segment is brought to you by
Beachbody oh my god I did the Beachbody
workout yesterday and I am so sorry I
know that you saw me walking that's
extra snatched the summer season isn't
on hold so your summer body shouldn't be
either get access to professional
training from the comfort of your own
home with Beachbody on demand thousands
joined Beachbody on demand to stay fit
during koban 19 and they weren't
disappointed Beachbody on demand gives
you instant access to over 1300 workouts
you can stream anytime so you can
maintain a consistent routine at home on
your own schedule this is the company
behind p90x insanity and 21 day fix so
now you can check out some of beach
bodies numerous programs like the
morning meltdown which I heard people
love to do a thorough after listening to
the morning toast it's a great combo and
80-day obsession and start every day
strong you can get motivated by super
trainers you know like Tony Horton joel
freeman jericho McMath use and autumn
Calabrese they have hundreds of
effective workouts from all fitness
levels including bodybuilding weight
training cardio yoga and even dance
workouts you can workout on your own
schedule for as short as 10 minutes and
it doesn't require any extra equipment
and the time it takes you to drive and
park at the gym you could be finished
doing a workout on Beachbody view it on
your computer your web-enabled TV a
tablet a smartphone a Roku an Apple TV a
chromecast really anywhere it's the best
deal in Fitness because listeners of the
morning toast can't ride absolutely free
so get a special free trial membership
txt toast to thirty thirty thirty that's
toas t two three zero three zero three
zero you'll get access to the entire
platform all the workouts nutritional
information and support absolutely free
just txt toast to thirty thirty thirty
that's toast to three zero three zero
three zero Thank You Beachbody for
sponsoring Deer toasters which is my
favorite day let's do it hi Claudia and
Jackie love you both in the show I work
in health care and your show has been a
Salvation during coronavirus thank you
so much for being a healthcare worker
you are a hero to everyone thank you I
am in need of sisterly advice and my
sister was supposed to get married this
August I found out around Christmas and
I'm pregnant with my first baby my
husband and I are thrilled my sister's
wedding date and my due date were
basically the same day her wedding was
planned for out of state and since I
would have needed to fly to attend the
wedding week and I wasn't gonna be able
to go I wasn't going to be able to go so
close to the baby being born we were
both upset but in order to
still on her special day I offered to
throw a very lavish wedding shower
weekend getaway for her and her friends
in her hometown where I still live
spending roughly what it would have cost
for me to attend the wedding
long story short karana virus came
canceling her wedding and postponing the
wedding until next summer
the good news is that I can now go to
the wedding the bad news is that she is
no longer speaking to me because she
wants me to still throw the expensive
wedding shower weekend and also attend
her wedding I understand that she's
frustrated about her events being
canceled I told her I would be happy to
throw her a smaller shower but I don't
think I can financially afford to throw
her the big shower and attend the
wedding not to mention that I have a new
baby to support yeah she has not spoken
to me since our conversation about this
two months ago and I'm five weeks away
from my due date am I wrong for not
doing both how can my sister and I start
talking again sincerely and expectant
toaster before we start I just have to
say I totally agree with you and you are
totally right you have a baby to worry
about like your life has changed and you
still want to be a supportive sister and
it sounds like you are but we need to
give all coronavirus brides like a
little bit of a break because they are
having a hard today are going through it
I thought that like they could postpone
their wedding three three months and
like no they can't like they're all
postponing it a year they're persuading
in a year with like the option for wave2
yet to make them postpone it again so I
agree coronavirus brides like I'm I'm
really so sorry for you but I will say
baby in five weeks
Trump's wedding so so right now you need
to prioritize yourself don't get too
stressed about it it's not good for the
baby
I think that maybe what you could say to
her is that you'll do a shower for her
maybe in the fall you can pretend like
it's the big shower but no like to
yourself that you're scaling down she
won't know like what the big shower
would be versus the little shower do
what you can for her and honestly if
it's not enough I feel like right now
anything that people can do for other
people or to you know have some sort of
good time like it's more than an omelet
will do the dumbest things and we're
like what a great night totally like
playing Monopoly like I'm so that we did
that so like if anyone's gonna be like I
want more it's just you know this isn't
the time for more so I think that if you
can do what you can come the fall after
your baby is born I think she should
appreciate that if she doesn't don't get
too bent out of shape about it you have
a new baby to worry about and is now
auntie's of a new baby like that baby is
the only thing that matter
and you know what like the baby will fix
everything like there it just I don't
know part of me like honestly in my
opinion what the bride is doing to the
pregnant sister is unforgivable but
because the bride is going through it
and we're giving coronavirus brides like
a little bit of a break I will I will
allow you to talk to her I will allow it
but honestly I feel like to get mad at a
pregnant woman for not bending over
backwards for you is like a little
unreasonable and liked it for not
spending money when she's having a baby
we're living through like an economic
crisis right I just I'll give her a
little bit of break because she's going
through the to going through it - but
baby Trump's all and that babies all
that matter and in the normal world what
she's doing in my opinion is
unforgivable yes but so we'll give her a
chance if you are up to it maybe try and
plan a little something but if but if
you're not up to it like you're [ __ ]
pregnant take care of yourself you don't
go out in a pandemic like just look out
for yourself in your child yeah and if
she's really gonna write you off because
of that she's got stuff to work on yeah
and she'll work through it and then you
two will get back together yeah okay
next up hello my beautiful stunning and
smart hosts to make a very long story
short I was in a very on and off
relationship for two years when I found
out that my now ex-boyfriend and best
friend whom I lived with during the time
we dated had been DMing she messaged
back kissy face emojis she now claims
she had no idea who he was his instant
name is a spin-off of his real name
similar to Claude with no job not that
far of a jump to figure out his profile
is private and his private his profile
pic with his sunglasses on in a hat I
don't trust her around men I date now
but I'm having a hard time cutting her
out of my life right now because of all
the drama it would cause am I being
crazy or should I cut her out of my life
I'm a maid of honor and she's getting
married this year for context she has
cheated on her fiance before with
another man the mess the message is my
man wait for context she has cheated on
her fiance before with another man then
messaging my man and physically cheating
with different men both happened about
five months before she got engaged her
fiance supposedly knows about both
okay I'm conveniently there's a lot like
that's not totally kosher here but I
will say I'm tempted to give her the
benefit of the doubt about the private
profile sunglasses and a hat and her not
knowing that she was talking to your man
I think that that's a good possum
that that's true oh I don't I also just
wouldn't trust someone like this around
future relationships cuz she obviously
has no real respect right or
relationship or otherwise he doesn't
even respect her own so I would
definitely be trepidatious of her in
general but I actually think that she
might have not known that she was
talking to your man so she just thought
she was talking to a random person and
happens to be her roommates boyfriend
yeah like the roommates boyfriend
reached out to her because he knew her
but she didn't realize like that this
was his Instagram I don't know it's a
tattoo Westbrook a little too convenient
she's obviously toxic it doesn't matter
she's right like you need to keep her at
arm's length period so whether she did
or she did in I just like to give people
the benefit of the doubt they don't
believe that people aren't as bad as
they can be so but sometimes they aren't
regardless I've just arms length or arms
like six feet apart someday emotionally
emotionally physically emotionally
mentally spiritually definitely alright
our final two your toasters hello ladies
first off thank you so much for still
providing loads of premium content
during these quarren times thank you
thank you for your appreciation that
means a lot so the story sounds insane
but my friend let's call it Jane insane
Jane
recently ended a five-year engagement
with a man 21 year old years older than
her luckily it happened just before
quarantine so she got out and was able
to move home she now lives with her mom
her mom's boyfriend who shall never
marry just for personal reasons but they
call him stepdad and her mom's
boyfriend's son I'll call him the
stepbrother I see Josh so on Easter she
facetimes me and informs me that she has
kissed her stepbrother when she was
tipsy she wasn't mad about it Serena dad
yes but I so Sharon Josh also on Easter
her ex-fiancée's mother passed away from
coronavirus complications so he reached
back out for her to comfort etcetera and
they ended up having phone sex that took
place on Monday and Tuesday after
Eastern so obviously this girl has a lot
going on
then she facetimes me on Thursday to
chat about all of this because she's
emotionally confused and informs me that
she not only had these FaceTime sessions
with her ex right after his mom died and
she kissed her stepbrother but then she
tells me that Wednesday she gave her
stepbrother a [ __ ] and he fingered
her
so high school lol Wow the way that this
is written is crazy she keeps asking me
what I think she should do and I keep
saying to stop hand [ __ ] your
stepbrother but she is starting to catch
feelings but also her relationship
beforehand was toxic so she needs to not
go back to that either I'm not sure what
advice I need to give besides like what
the [ __ ] do I tell her I just thought
this story was actually insane and that
you guys would get a kick out of it
during to your toasters because it is
one of the most insane stories I've ever
heard I am happy to provide updates if
needed love you guys and thank you both
stay safe during these times
sincerely incest is not best there are
two things going on here first is a
relationship with the ex-boyfriend who
terrible without his mom passed away
from current virus-like absolutely awful
and I get that she like wanted to be
there for him this is like in Riverdale
when Archie's dad got shot and like
Veronica thought it'd be helpful to get
in the shower with him but some people
just need comfort during times like that
and I don't necessarily fault her like
she shouldn't go back to a toxic
relationship even though like he
obviously needs someone right now that
it just it can't be you
with the stepbrother like I don't see
why that's problematic I know but maybe
we're also like I don't see why it's
problematic either but that's just
because of the like examples that have
been set forward to me like by
entertainment programming so I share my
gosh Serena and Dan even Betty and
Jughead because their parents were
dating and they were dating
yeah that's not incest but no but that's
exactly what's happening here their
parents are together they're not getting
married even say got married it doesn't
change the blood their parents were
dating these people have been together
for 15 years I think she said okay but
like that it's still going
it's a family but you know what they
could be family on to friends you know
what they're doing craziest thing I've
ever heard and you know what like if
this is her OTP this is so cute so cute
by the way first of all there's some
there's a huge difference between dating
your mom's boyfriend's son and your
stepdads son but they're not married but
they call him step ahead and make him
their stepdad but they called him is so
biologically he's not your stepbrother
and legally he's not your stepbrother so
he's just the guy yeah who's living in
your house looking for love yeah no I
like I think this is an interesting way
to have met someone and speaking of
there's this new trend on tik-tok where
it's like and it went like and the
people talk about like how they met
their significant others and it's so
random where it's like
her mom's a professor and she went to
study abroad with her and there was like
one of the other teachers is bringing
their son and like that's how they met
and this is I feel like one of those
stories like a whirlwind romance yeah
it's definitely not conventional but
love is you know what it's hard
love isn't conventional you guys and I
think that's what you should take from
this episode I think so too but
definitely don't get back don't
encourage her to get back with the Toxic
know for him also a five-year engagement
like it's done but he needed you during
that time and you were there for him but
the FaceTime sex and for that you served
a purpose and that was the right thing
to do
yeah no I'm not even bent out of shape
about that even if he'd like even if you
guys were just exes and there wasn't the
factor of him going through tragedy and
grieving like you can have FaceTime sex
with your ex during quarantine harmless
anyway harmless um so those are our tear
toasters again if you ever want to write
in we always keep it anonymous and you
can write us about anything
so it's dear toasters at gmail.com we
appreciate all the entries and that's
our show anything else nope that is all
she wrote I see her and she's like
typing away make sure you how I see her
as handwriting this oh I see her as a
21st century girl Oh interesting
yes she's Carrie Bradshaw with her
laptop so we have an hour last show of
the week is for tomorrow but please make
sure to order my special review at rated
I really appreciate the support and
that's all she wrote thank you guys so
much flows into the morning to us the
millennium morning show or we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found Spotify
iTunes stitcher Public Radio IR marina
cash box all the places whoever you
listen to podcast find us more neato
sleeve a 5 star review about a beautiful
something a smart we our end you can now
watch our videos on Spotify they have
allowed podcasters to upload videos
which is great so that's what we're
doing and that's all she wrote that is
all she wrote
bye-bye